[Music]
Barcelona femini are the best women's
team in Spain growing up watching
Barcelona on TV I never thought that
would step foot on on camp Camp Noob
they are also the best women's team in
Europe champions
they have the world's top player for
game's most expensive signing and the
highest revenue in Europe
it's a revolution it's a social
Revolution so how did they do it and can
basa help Spanish women's football take
off if we invest we are going to be
the public for sure because we have
everything
[Music]
few people know the story of Barcelona
femini better than its captain
Spanish International she's been with
the club for a decade since before it
turned professional and long before it
conquered European football is
[Music]
foreign
big International Stars including the
most expensive transfer fee ever paid in
women's football Kara Walsh midfielder
Walsh was part of the England team that
won Euro 2022 helping to catapult
women's football into the mainstream
since then attendances at matches in
England's women's Super League have
surged but the pull of playing for one
of football's most storied clubs proved
strong enough to lure her to Spain
yeah I think when a club like Barcelona
comes in for you it's very difficult to
say no and I think after the euros and
you know how successful England was I
think yeah that kind of happened after
that and yeah I was very excited once I
received the phone call and spoke to my
family about it and yeah I think for all
it was it was a no-brainer to come here
so when you come here it's the
atmosphere and training in terms of
competitiveness and wanting to win and
I just think they go that extra mile to
to ensure that the women's team is in
the best place to win and it's a
football culture it's not just about a
men's and women's team they just love
football and you could really feel that
when I was on the bus parade and I see
people with Alexis shirt I Tanisha over
men's players shirts and for me you know
that's such a massive thing to see now
with women's football going forward
the women's team in Barcelona has Deep
Roots early Games took place as long ago
as the 1970s with the team fully
absorbed into the Barcelona Sports Group
in 2002 but it took until 2015 for the
club to turn professional putting it at
the same level as other sports in the
Barcelona Empire such as basketball and
handball since then growth has been
accelerated in tandem with a broader
boom in women's sport
the team six thousand seater Stadium on
the outskirts of town is typically sold
out and an increasing number of games
are held at the iconic Camp new where
the record attendance for a woman's game
was set against Wolfsburg in 2022
one man in particular has been at the
heart of driving the changes
Sports director of FC Barcelona women's
team
the son of legendary Spanish goalkeeper
Anthony zubisareta Markle has been with
bassa's women team since it went
professional he's been tasked with
improving everything from player
training to Talent spotting I entered to
the club in 2015 and the first game
maybe we had
300 fans in the in the pitch we were
playing in a in Turf in the training
center and maybe the boys the team of
the boys under 16 has preference in the
pits with us so from that point was to
build a lot of things into have
goals
every year to try to increase later by
little and to know that our
we were building a project inside the
club that has a legacy in terms of
football now we have another part of the
club that is professional we want to be
one of the top teams in in the world and
we are going to invest in that
the club also hopes to build a pipeline
of talent in the same way it has for the
men's team
the club's legendary Youth Academy
female footballers are now living on
site and receiving the same experience
as the likes of Lionel Messi Andres
Iniesta and Pep Guardiola
one of the former students here Alexia
poteas has gone on to become the top
player in women's football winning the
Ballon d'Or twice
Mike puj is responsible for the
day-to-day running of La marseilla which
now has over 100 full-time students
living on campus
13 of them are girls and young women
hoping to break into the Barca first
team following the path well-trodden by
some of the biggest names in global
football we have players from 11 years
old till 21 22 years old and they come
here the expectations are to to be in
the best Academy in the world so this is
our responsibility to keep these
expectations very high Our Girls when
they are young they used to play against
boys in their competitions because we
want them to to play hard and and to
develop us as soon as possible as quick
as possible
success on the pitch has led to
financial gains just one big match at
the Camp nou can generate over 1 million
euros from ticket sales in 2022 basa
femini recorded income of just under 8
million the highest in Europe but those
numbers are a tiny fraction of what the
men's team brings in which is why
salaries for female players across
football are so much lower than for
their male counterparts
one of the problems Barcelona faces is a
lack of competition at home
the Spanish women's league Liga Fe has
only just completed its first season as
a fully professional competition putting
it behind some of its European Rivals
Barcelona lost one match all season and
has been defeated in the league just
three times in the last four years
the lack of Jeopardy in Liga fa is a
problem and risks making it less
appealing to the fans sponsors and
broadcasters who will help fund the
nascent contest
but those running the league are
optimistic that changes afoot as money
comes into the women's game and more
clubs start to see it as a business
opportunity it's a problem that is all
also in men's football we've seen
Premier League series six from the last
seven time I think or in Spain is always
useful Real Madrid or Barcelona no more
so did this forensics is very difficult
to to reduce it but we are working in in
the revenue or the incomings for the
collapse
get grow that grow and they could invest
in by its players it was a social
opportunity years ago and now it's a
business opportunity much of what is
happening at Barcelona and in Liga fa
will feel familiar to those working in
the women's game elsewhere a lack of
funding low levels of competition and
tepid interest from commercial Partners
have long held back the sport but change
is underway
Karen Carney former footballer chair of
the domestic review into the future of
women's football
khani a former England International has
been charged with carrying out a
wide-ranging review of football for the
English FA many of her findings hold
lessons that can be applied around the
world I think women's football I
wouldn't say it's at the very start
because it's been around for a while now
but I would say in its Journey it's it's
at its early part and I keep saying it I
still think it's a startup business
we've got to make the environment
professional has to be elite and then
once everything's in place then the
product will really grow and like I said
that once these women have the right
facilities are paid fairly are given the
opportunity then they will be able to
play better the game will be quicker
faster stronger then audiences will
attend more once you find a better
broadcasting slot then we'll be able to
watch it easier and more signposted on
TV then sponsors will come back in and
then we'll see The Virtuous cycle come
back in but we need that injection of
cash but there's still this taboo around
women's sport and women's football oh
it's going to cost it's going to cost
well everything does but I'm telling you
you'll get it back and this is what
needs to be done it's 2023.
Barcelona's experience shows that there
is a large and growing audience for
women's football
many of those people might be new to the
sport altogether
building a successful business from it
will require investment willpower and
most of all patience
[Applause]